[Music]
foreign
the stock market route this year has
clobbered investors with many of the
world's big fund managers striking out
and moving to the sidelines but that
hasn't been the case for one of the most
well-known investors billionaire Warren
Buffett
the chief executive of Berkshire
Hathaway has spent tens of billions of
dollars this year on stocks snapping up
shares of Citigroup HP Chevron and
Occidental he also clinched a 12 billion
dollar deal to buy insurer and toy
manufacturer Allegheny
the new bets marker returned to
Buffett's deal-making Roots which he had
largely put on ice after the pandemic
first rocked the U.S it was a move that
Drew criticism from shareholders as its
cash pile surged
Buffett was deeply worried about the
initial downturn sparked by the
coronavirus and sold stakes in U.S banks
and Airlines fearing large losses for
the businesses
that pessimistic view meant Buffett
passed on some of the best deals struck
in 2020 when other big money managers
including Apollo and Blackstone went to
work lending billions of dollars to
companies in trouble
by the time the clouds began to clear
Buffett had missed out stocks were
rallying aggressively and the returns no
longer looked appealing
Buffett at one point warned that the
market was quote almost totally a casino
as it skyrocketed instead of diving in
he stuck to his Playbook but sat on the
sides spending money on one thing he
thought was undervalued Berkshire
Hathaway's own stock
the company's cash pile was near record
territory when the value of other stocks
began to Crater
to get buff at the Firepower to go in a
buying spree for bargains
in April he said that during the market
sell-off this year quote a few stocks
got very interesting to us and we also
spent a lot of money
his pace of deal making has slowed as
the market has rebounded this summer but
with the S P 500 still in a bear Market
it's possible there are other deals in
the wings for Buffett